[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je suis Lucienne j'ai 60 ans je
travaille comme secrétaire d'édition
montrer la randonnée une archéologie
j'ai 47 ans je suis fonctionné mon
triple c'est d'apprendre la tagline une
maçonnerie marocaine
[Applaudissements]
je m'appelle Olivia j'ai 28 ans et mon
fric Cédric dans le sud du Maroc pour me
perfectionner dans ma nouvelle passion
qui est la pratique du surf
[Musique]
trois voyageurs 3 générations trois
passions mais aujourd'hui une seule
destination le Maroc tous rêvent de s'y
rendre depuis toujours mais chacun est
animée par un objectif différent
Christian aimerait devenir artisan il
part à Marrakech pour une formation au
tas de lac à savoir faire typiquement
marocain à l'issue de son voyage une
éventuelle reconversion professionnelle
c'était en Guadeloupe une fois avec ma
femme après on a été
[Musique]
en Crète et voilà les deux saloyages que
j'ai fait pour l'instant
et le troisième
[Musique]
Olivia Saket se perfectionner dans ce
sport
la semaine ça va être
plein de belles choses dans la tête ça
va être soufflé ça va être se gaver de
de mer de soleil de belles images de
belles lumières parce qu'ici il y a que
ça et voilà
[Musique]
Lucienne elle par soutenir l'action
d'une association dans une vallée
reculée de l'Atlas un trek solidaire
animé par une quête personnelle la
recherche de gravures préhistorique
moi les cailloux c'est ma passion les
cailloux les vieaux ce type de voyage je
ne pensais pas le faire parce que je
pensais que c'était dans des
destinations trop lointaines mais la
voilà c'est l'autre rive de la
Méditerranée et le Maghreb ça m'a
beaucoup fasciné toujours le côté cite
et découverte des gravures rupestres
satellites voilà le côté archéologique
a-t-il déclic
[Musique]
aujourd'hui Olivia Christian et Lucienne
commencent une aventure singulière mais
ce voyage va-t-il répondre à toutes
leurs attentes
[Musique]
à une heure de route de Marrakech la
petite ville de tegwin est l'une des
portes d'entrée vers les montagnes du
Haut Atlas avant d'arpenter cette vallée
couper des circuits touristiques
Lucienne et ses nouveaux compagnons
d'aventure sont accueillis par
l'association Les Amis du service
tout ce qu'on va partager au cours
on cherche on va passer des femmes
la présentation
[Musique]
la vallée on va passer deux jours pour
découvrir les villages de la haute
Valley et des gorges puis on va faire
une ascension une à 100 m 900 m c'est
chaud quand même je monterai sur les
épaules de Robert
[Musique]
donc ça m'inquiète un petit peu voilà
mais c'est tout non
je puiserais dans mes ressources non
mais c'est surtout que là-haut il y a
les gravures je serai très motivée alors
à quatre pattes il le faut mais
j'arriverai pas là parce que moi 900
mètres ça me fait penser à ce que j'ai
fait valait des merveilles écorce mais
c'était il y a 30 ans voilà et là je
montais beaucoup plus vite non mais ça
ira c'est très bien ça ira
jusqu'à présent tout va bien
[Musique]
mon baptême de 4x4 et bon je fais que
regretter qu'il fasse nuit mais je me
suis dit ce sera encore plus beau demain
voilà c'était super
maintenant Lucienne s'est un peu mieux
ce qu'il attend pour mériter le
spectacle des gravures elle doit d'abord
franchir l'école escarpins qui entoure
la vallée du zate à pied
à Marrakech Christian plonge dans un
monde totalement nouveau pour lui et
fait ses premiers pas au Maroc à plus de
2000 km de son village normand je pense
que ça va être une aventure et puis même
sur le Time lac et puis après pour les
visiter j'ai jamais mis les pieds à
Marrakech
[Musique]
c'est vraiment comme un safari une
aventure et qui va se qui va s'ouvrir à
moi
faire son stage de tête lac est situé en
plein cœur de la médina la vieille ville
de Marrakech c'est aussi la maison de
Saïd l'ami qu'il a invité à passer une
semaine ici c'est parti
alors au stage aux vacances pour les
vacances
c'est quelqu'un que j'ai connu en France
et on est des bons amis il savait que
j'aimais bien bricoler et il m'a parlé
du Time light et qui m'a accroché pour
venir apprendre au Maroc parce que il y
a qu'au Maroc on peut vraiment avoir la
bonne technique c'est un Marocain et
puis en France on a peut-être des stages
mais pas aussi perfectionné qu'on peut
trouver au Maroc
nous ce qu'on propose le programme 6
heures de stage par jour avec avec une
pause avec deux poses une pause le matin
une pause l'après-midi et le repas c'est
le repas de midi en revanche si les gens
préfèrent finir commencer tôt et finir
tôt pour aller se balader il y a pas de
problème c'est vrai que vous êtes venus
pour faire un stage mais il y a aussi
autre chose à faire et vous inquiétez
pas pour ceux qui aiment bien faire la
fête que ceux qui viennent manger voire
de belles choses il y a des choses à
faire
maintenant on va visiter une chambre que
j'adore et après je te mets dans l'autre
chambre toute la maison est fait avec du
tas de l'axe donc tu vois les j'adore
qu'on peut faire on peut faire jusqu'à
256 couleurs de tas de là je pensais que
ça allait être un peu rugueux et puis
c'est très lisse comme de la cire c'est
un comme si on avait passé une couche
Verney qui a pas de vernis c'est
vraiment
très impressionnant quand tu auras fini
ton stage tu te feras comme ça voir
mieux vraiment envie de d'apprendre
bon ben j'arrive à 47 ans et puis bon là
ce voyage peut m'apporter beaucoup de
choses pour changer de métier et puis de
me lancer
un boulot artisanal Christian a toutes
les raisons d'être impatient s'il
maîtrise Satan du mur à la fin du stage
se passionner de bricolage pourra
peut-être enfin réaliser son rêve
devenir artisan en France
le soleil se lève sur la côte et Olivia
peut enfin admirer le spectacle qu'elle
attend depuis des mois d'evagues qu'elle
avait admiré dans les magazines mais qui
face à elle sont nettement plus
impressionnantes qu'elle ne l'imaginait
elle appréhende ce moment plein de spots
différents toutes les vagues et c'est
vrai que quand on vient pour surfer au
Maroc c'est vraiment pour moi c'est le
paradis
point de la batailleuse
la belle vie une belle vie
des spots c'est pas la bonne marée pour
nous pour surfer le temps que la marée
commence à descendre là on pourra
choisir un spot où on peut se poser et
surfer
on y va
on commence à partir
sur ce spot apprécié des surfeurs les
plus expérimentés Olivia savoure le
spectacle et bien aussi de comprendre
que l'apprentissage du surf ne sera pas
qu'une partie de plaisir
[Musique]
on va aller se balader on va faire un
peu le spot le spectacle s'il y a des
s'il y a des surfeurs ce qu'ils
annoncent quand même trois quatre mètres
aujourd'hui on essayera de trouver un
spot pour tout le monde cet après-midi
donc là tu vois c'est la pointe des
encres le spot le plus connu au Maroc
bon c'est peut-être là où le de l'année
on a pas eu aussi gros
cette année
quand tu passes là dedans c'est une
machine à laver
spectacle de la nature c'est
impressionnant d'évacuer comme ça
comme disait Ahmed là dans l'eau que des
sportifs de haut niveau quoi je pense
que au niveau adrénaline on doit on doit
ressentir quelque chose de très très
fort mais moi c'est parce que je
recherche je suis admirative avec les
tonnes d'eau de pression que qu'on se
prend sur le corps
à nous moi je supporte pas écraser comme
une petite mouche
c'est beau
c'est mort
Lucienne va devoir elle aussi faire
preuve d'endurance car la journée
s'annonce difficile au programme 6
heures de marche et 900 mètres de
dénivelé elle s'assure auprès de magie
que tout est bien prêt pour la censure
je pensais qu'elles ont juste les
couffins et non pas une armature
métallique dans lesquelles on mettrait
les sacs
de gros sacs
ça va comme auteur c'est pas trop trop
grand
j'essaie de le faire je suis pas arrivé
quand c'est toi qui le fais ça a l'air
tellement simple merci Mehdi c'est bon
c'est bon
j'ai regardé la carte et j'ai regardé
les courbes de niveau
les courbes de niveau sont quand même un
peu chaudes enfin nous laisserons pas
agoniser toute seule non ça va
c'était drôle c'est que on dirait avoir
tout cet effervescence compare pour
réaliser quelque chose d'extraordinaire
alors que c'est rien pour nous pas pour
les gens d'ici
demain j'ai déjà mal à la tête avant de
partir
on est toujours prêt
depuis son arrivée dans la vallée
d'usade Lucienne la passionné
d'archéologie n'a pas encore eu
l'occasion d'admirer les gravures tant
convoitées avec Robert elle s'est trouvé
un compagnon d'ascension jusqu'au lieu
qui concentre le plus de vestiges le
plateau du yaourt je pense que marcher
c'est quelque chose extraordinaire
d'ailleurs lorsque tu es dans un groupe
de randonneurs aguerris comme eux il
faut suivre de moi je suis une simple
promeneuse je suis pas une randonneuse
avertie enfin j'ai de l'endurance voilà
chaque fois que je vois des gens qui
vivent comme il y a 1000 ou 2000 ou 3000
ans j'ai beaucoup de respect parce que
je trouve ça mirable ça me parle mais
moi je me bien vivre dans le passé dans
la tête dans le passé voilà et en même
temps que je vous parle je regarde s'il
y a pas des pointes de flèche mais on
n'a pas non il y a rien là c'est pas une
terre à silex et des pointes de flèches
en ont les pointes de flèche on les
trouve plutôt dans les zones de pleines
donc du enfin du désert plus au sud et
où le vent à souffle donc ça dénude les
fossiles et les flèches cela étant comme
je suis respectueuse du pays en principe
quand on en trouve il faut les laisser
par respect il faut pas piller les sites
mais c'est dur de résister à la
tentation voilà
[Musique]
allez on descend
tout droit
la peau pour faire pipi
après on prend un peu le soleil
puis à côté de moi 500lier tu vois il
manque tout droit il a pas peur moi je
m'agrippe un peu parce que ça va quand
même les genoux ils tiennent encore tu
as vu le week-end regarde je crois que
c'est un centimètre par siècle je veux
dire un caillou c'est pas vivant mais ça
c'est vivant tu penses qu'il y a
peut-être 10.000 ans un berger monté il
s'appuie là comment on fait nous tu vois
comme ceux de d'en bas bien sûr
il est trop bien là
[Musique]
à une centaine de kilomètres de la
vallée du zat le Riad dans lequel s'est
installé Christian résonne de son bien
nouveau pour lui un Marrakech on est
baigné dans le pays on est vraiment dans
l'ambiance de taglak
au départ moi je suis boulanger et bon
ben j'ai travaillé en usine puis après
tout le reste de mes corps de métiers
j'ai appris moi-même en pratiquant une
semaine c'est bien court pour apprendre
un métier Christian n'a pas vraiment le
choix il va falloir travailler dur pour
être au point
les explications pour le démarrage avec
le professeur
comme un apprenti j'arrive comment
apprenti je veux vraiment arriver et à
prendre directement sur le tas on y va
en fait c'est une fois qu'on a fini le
travail là c'est tout ce qui est au sol
tout ce qui est sur le mur tout ce qui
est fini ça c'est de la chaux avec de
l'eau donc pour un sac de chaud on met
un seau d'eau et une fois qu'on aura
fini ça s'appelle
aujourd'hui on va faire des petits
exemples des échantillons faire et
refaire faire et refaire faire face
qu'est-ce que ça rentre c'est parti tout
le monde peut venir pratiquer le
timeline c'est pas un métier très dur
mais bon après c'est au niveau des bras
de bien avoir le mouvement c'est
pratiqué à remonter à refaire de faire
un refaire jusqu'à acquérir la
perfection qu'il faut pour le taglac je
m'attendais pas quelque chose de très
dur à faire
pas l'air d'être concluant
ça me plaît pas trop
conscience qu'on a envie qu'une personne
qui maîtrise le métier moi j'ai
confiance en Lui moi j'ai confiance à ce
que j'enseigne je suis que tous ces gens
là ils seront capables de faire leur
maison j'ai une maison en France comme
Christian m'avait aidé à construire ma
maison j'ai proposé de venir ici pour
apprendre de tas de l'axe pour le faire
chez moi voyons un double enjeu l'enjeu
c'est que Christian apprend et qu'il
soit content de ce qu'il a appris et moi
ce qu'il apprend et que je sois content
de ce qu'il a pris parce qu'il va faire
ma maison en France
[Musique]
depuis les années 80 la région d'Agadir
est devenue l'un des rendez-vous des
surfeurs du monde entier sur une
centaine de kilomètres il se retrouve
pour pratiquer ensemble leur sport
favori aujourd'hui c'est au tour
d'Olivia de se jeter à l'eau
[Musique]
elles sont belles elles sont grosses
qui part vers la gauche alors tout en
pour rentrer il faut l'enlever les
rochers de la droite utiliser le contre
courant et comme ça vous vous rendez
compte OK
bon il faut faire un tout petit peu
attention là parce que j'avais un orage
on a eu toutes les rivières qui ont
déversé sur les plages il faut vraiment
faire gaffe ou vous mettez vos pieds et
où vous marchez OK
le surf c'est pas pareil que les autres
sports première journée deuxième journée
tu vas doucement c'est comme du diesel
quoi tu fais chauffer ton corps tout
doucement
[Musique]
avec les échauffements ça va aller
on va rien se casser on espère
voilà ça commence maintenant dans la
mousse joue avec balancement de ton
corps pour garder la planche toujours en
plat si tu vois qu'elle part trop avec
le nom ce qu'elle va piquer du nez mais
un peu de poids vers l'arrière elle a
planche automatiquement elle va faire ça
les genoux pliés tout le temps et voilà
tu joues avec ta barre ton balance de
quoi ok
le but de la semaine c'est de la faire
passer la barre et positionnement sur la
planche même si elle change de planche
elle saura ou mettre ses pieds le
positionnement de pied
[Musique]
je suis très débutante mais le plaisir
c'est d'être dans l'eau d'apprendre à
chaque vague à chaque gamme elle surtout
et puis de sortir d'une session avec la
tête vider et le sourire jusqu'aux
oreilles ouais c'est ça
elle reforme au milieu de la plage et ça
fait une grosse mousse au milieu ce qui
est vrai bien bien bien bien pour ceux
qui apprennent comme ça ça leur donne un
grand espace où il y a une mousse qui
déroule
elle est pas belle la vie
les
coudramments de Tarek Olivia n'est pas
encore arrivé au bout de ses peines pour
tenir debout sur sa planche
première journée la programmer là il y a
trop de courant la vague elle est
puissante là elle est en train de se
fatiguer comme pas possible et quand tu
es fatigué c'est même pas la peine de
chercher
ça fatigue maintenant
et surtout surtout ne sois pas droite
comme ça tu as un centre de gravité il
faut que tu sois appropriée voilà et là
tout encore une fois vers elle
plus important
[Musique]
dans la vallée du zat Lucienne et ses
compagnons de marche n'en sont eux qu'à
la moitié de l'Ascension lunettes
casquette
voilà la moitié du temps au lieu
d'appuyer sur le déclencheur j'appuie
pour éteindre tu vois tellement je suis
doué moi en fait je suis une femme de la
préhistoire qui vise là donc
voilà et tu penses que là on a un temps
une espérée un temps de rêve tu aurais
fait 36 15 dieux tu aurais pas eu mieux
voilà ce que j'ai fait d'ailleurs
chaque traversée de village est
l'occasion de faire une halte pour
découvrir la vie des paysans berbères
aujourd'hui l'arrêt a lieu chez Hassan à
tizirte dans le fait peur
[Musique]
pour savoir qu'est-ce qu'ils pensent de
nous je sais pas comment il juge notre
démarche
du temps des parents des grands-parents
des arrières grands-parents ça a pas
changé moi j'ai beaucoup de respect pour
ce genre là mais ils vivent comme il y a
500 ans
[Musique]
merci beaucoup nous a fait un grand
honneur d'être reçu dans la maison on
apprécie beaucoup
la seule chose qui est un petit peu
difficile pour moi bien sûr que c'est
quand ça craint un peu trop Théodore
Monod a fait avant moi se plaisent
c'est la chaleur qui est le plus
terrible le reste c'est bon
la chaleur c'est un peu chaud un peu
trop
alors là
c'est autre chose
faut s'attendez pas avoir un plateau ça
fait presque une cuvette volcanique en
fait regarde
[Musique]
pas pourquoi vous m'applaudissez vous
l'avez tous fait alors
bonjour tout le monde
elles sont où les gravures
là-bas au bout du plateau on peut pas y
aller tout de suite
moi je vais le voir quelque chose
regarde ça on dirait une plage fossile
ça c'est vraiment surprenant cette
pierre dont j'ignore et la composition
et la date mais qui me parle comme on
dit et qui m'évoque le reflux de la mère
donc des empreintes sur le sable mais je
pense que c'est pas du tout ça mais en
tous les cas elle est très belle et là
pour moi c'est un cadeau non mais j'ai
dit que c'était une plage fossile pour
rêver quand il y avait la mer jusqu'ici
tu vois
des fossiles dans des strates
sédimentaires de la roche du calcaire
donc fossile donc il y avait la mer il y
a X X millions d'années
voilà donc partout où il y a et là c'est
du silex c'est-à-dire sur presque la
terre entière et ben je me sens plus
chez moi voilà
enfin bref demain c'est la gravure
le plus dur est passé pour Lucienne elle
se rapproche du but Christian lui est
toujours enfermé dans son Riyad pour
apprendre il n'a pas encore résolu tous
les mystères du tas de lacs
[Musique]
comme ça
on commence à bien pratiquer mais bon on
n'est pas au point à 100% quand même
mais bon je pense qu'à la fin du sol on
sera déjà encore plus performant que
aujourd'hui mon chemin
déjà de te rendre compte
ça peut mouillant
en même temps
ah bon je vais avoir une qualité de
quelqu'un de très manuel mais bon même
une personne qui est pas trop manuelle
arrête quand même à prendre les bases il
y a pas de problème faut pas être quand
même professionnel pour venir faire le
stage
[Musique]
apprendre tout de suite c'est prenant
c'est passionnant
[Musique]
je redémonte et je remonte jusqu'à temps
de d'avoir à peu près la perfection qui
va falloir
bien avoir la touche une forme partout
la première couche
de formater
faut profiter en dehors de ça quand même
du Maroc il faut sortir et voir
l'extérieur comme direction le grand
souk de Marrakech temple du commerce ou
Christian a bien l'intention de faire
des affaires il espère se servir de son
maillot de l'équipe de France de
football championne du monde pour
faciliter les contacts
[Musique]
c'est pour des paysans c'est agréable
les gens sont pas à nous souhaiter
dessus pour agressif très souriant sans
problème plus loin on va trouver des
artisans les vrais artisans c'est à dire
ceux qui fabriquent vraiment l'artisanat
marocain il y a un quartier pour là où
ils font les babouches il y a un
quartier là où ils font des phares
forgés enfin chaque quartier est un peu
spécialisé quoi
donc on va le voir
[Musique]
on s'enrichit de voir que des gens qui
travaillent avec très peu de choses et
qui ont une maîtrise du métier
artisanale important
en France on nous trouvons pas cette
maîtrise des outils modernes que de la
récupération si on prend son la mais
avec les tours à bois mais pas
emmanuellement d'ailleurs on serait très
malheureux si on avait plus
d'électricité en rapport à eux on est on
est plus moderne mais finalement deux
trous peut-être aussi on aurait pas mal
de choses à apprendre sur que ça soit
sur la fonderie sur le bois sur le cuir
sans problème
Christian le passionné d'artisanat est
impressionné mais il n'est pas encore au
bout de ses surprises après le souk il
se rend sur l'un des sites les plus
emblématiques de Marrakech la place Jama
el-Fna au milieu des musiciens et des
danseurs qui font le spectacle il a
trouvé le moyen de pratiquer une autre
activité
le patient c'est la pêche
de coca c'est la première fois de ma vie
[Musique]
Louna
oui
pendant que Christian goutte aux JO de
tourisme ordinaire Olivia et son groupe
de surfeurs quitte leur spot pour en
gagner un autre un peu plus au sud de la
côte marocaine ils ont rendez-vous à
tagazout un petit village Gothier qui
est devenu en quelques années la Mecque
des surfeurs tagazout un arrêt
obligatoire pour qui veut faire réparer
son matériel
j'avais entendu parler de tarasite par
mon professeur de surf quand je j'ai
commencé à surfer donc en Bretagne c'est
vrai quand on dit tarrasou c'est
vraiment le surf au Maroc vous êtes
d'ici oui vous êtes de
toi et vous surfer aussi
un petit peu comme ça
c'est l'atelier de réparation pour les
planches
la planche là
et après on pète là cet après-midi
sans arrêt
résine c'est nocif elle se fait là comme
ça
dans la rue en fait et avec juste les
petites ampoules qui éclairent ils font
ça avec les moyens du bord mais toutes
les planches du camp on sort quand elles
sont réparées ici
on y va
végétation le petit bar c'est vrai que
voilà tout ça ça fait l'ambiance d'ici
[Musique]
la planche Olivia doit encore faire des
progrès en surf
[Musique]
Jean-Claude il attaque une petite
quatrième assiette donc il y a toujours
à ta première
mais tu peux pas
déjà
pour le ciel la nuit sera court dans
quelques heures elle pourra pleinement
apprécié son voyage et après une ultime
ascension se plonger dans l'archéologie
[Musique]
sur ce plateau immense au cœur de la
vallée des pasteurs et des éleveurs ont
laissé depuis des siècles des empreintes
fragiles Lucienne fait partie des rares
passionnés avoir eu la chance de les
observer de ses propres yeux même pas
demandé ce que ça représente je veux pas
savoir je veux le voir sur place les
gravures j'ai la typologie dans la tête
mais j'attends de les voir
on comprend vraiment pourquoi elles ont
choisi cet endroit vu les dalles
je le vois là-haut je l'ai vu un disque
tu as vu que je l'avais tout de suite
ça pouvait elle pouvait elle pouvait
être que là
je suis pas dessus marche pas dessus
ah ça c'est
vous voyez un soleil qui domine les
sommets
de Gouline il a le même le sommet existe
gravé dans ce disque et même il y a la
vallée
moi je pensais que c'était d'une
audithique tu vois vraiment 5000 6000
7000 mais c'est 600 c'est gravure qu'on
voit maintenant
sont dater
de 600 jusqu'à 1800 avant Jésus-Christ
il y a poignard des boucliers
c'est sûr qu'on n'a pas pu les graver
avant l'utilisation de la métallurgie
voilà voilà on va voir les autres
[Musique]
la vache de la vache
c'est magnifique
c'est le là aussi elle est bien patinée
moi j'aime bien mettre mes doigts
plus
pour compter les troupeau tu vois mais
en fait j'en sais rien
et non on n'en sait rien lui il a pris
le couteau dans le cœur
c'est beau
[Musique]
merci de nous avoir amené là tu vois
quand contrairement à ce qu'on pense
c'est pas parce que tu es très attiré
par la préhistoire que tu t'intéresses
qu'à ça je trouve que justement de voir
des gravures et 50 mètres plus loin de
voir les maisons habitées les champs
cultivés les bergers bien c'est
formidable
la vie
[Musique]
dans toute sa matière
pour moi-même pour aller la faire à la
maison et puis après pratiquer à
l'extérieur avant de faire chez said je
vais peut-être pratiquer pendant deux ou
trois semaines ou un mois à la maison
pour bien avoir les bonnes bases pour
pratiquer justement en France
salut
bonjour
[Musique]
je suis content ça va être beau chez
nous
c'est une chose que je voulais apprendre
à tout prix
je vois que ça que j'arrive à maîtriser
que facilement déjà une bonne maîtrise
quand même
en France le tas de Lac est à la mode
présent dans toutes les revues de
décoration mais ils sont peu à pouvoir
se targuer d'avoir appris à le maîtriser
la même où il puisse ses origines grâce
à ce voyage Christian a toutes les
chances de réaliser son rêve de devenir
artisan spécialisé en tas de laque
[Musique]
pour Olivia c'est la vague de la
dernière chance elle espère profiter de
ses derniers moments pour enfin surfer
avec
[Musique]
là je vais rectifier les positions des
pieds ok alors tu t'allonges sur la
planche
ici voilà tu fais rentrer genoux on va
tout droit les deux mains devant voilà
comme ça tu gardes ton équilibre et le
demain devant et tu regardes toujours en
face là où tu veux aller
pas en regardant tu regardes pas la
planche tu regardes pas tes pieds voilà
ça fixe
l'horizon pour toi et là tu es plus
stable maintenant tu es rentré et tu vas
prendre des vols et tu vas cliquer ça
exactement ça rien que ça OK
comment faire son positionnement de pied
sur la planche parce que temps en temps
elle fait des bons et une fois qu'elle
décide de prendre la gauche ou la droite
elle tombe direct c'est pour ça il
fallait que je lui explique mais sinon
on est en train d'essayer de lui fixer
ce petit défauts là mais la plupart des
cafards ils ont envie de d'avoir
d'autres sensations de glisse de faire
des figures des cuts des flotteurs et
tout oui
[Rires]
je vais te montrer là maintenant le surf
marocain
c'est l'apprentissage de la vague il
faut savoir ruser
je vais manger
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
après une journée de surf c'est à Agadir
qu'on recherche les batteries au marché
des poissons
[Musique]
on se baigne dans l'eau de mer toute la
journée on mange du poisson c'est
superbe
cet après-midi les règles du jeu ont un
peu changé pour Olivia ce n'est pas dans
l'eau mais sur le bitume qu'elle va
devoir montrer de quoi elle est capable
en matière d'équilibre alors là en fait
on domine la bête c'est magnifique et
ici on a un super terrain
pour pour le skate il paraît que c'est
très complémentaire avec le surf c'est
une grande planche avec avec des
ressorts et résultat au niveau des des
manœuvres de savoir faire un petit peu
de skate de s'entraîner comme ça ça peut
ça peut aider quoi prendre du don
moi je préfère faire ça c'est mon
dangereux je pense ouais j'ai peur de
tomber
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
dans le nez quoi
c'est physique c'est pas physique
[Applaudissements]
moi la première forme si tu regarderas
Rachid au début je comprenais pas de en
fait Rachid c'est ce qui a marqué sur le
mur
c'est con mais super sensation moi
j'adore j'adore c'est fou les enfants
plus on commence petit que ça soit le
surf ou ça au niveau du corps on n'est
pas pareil
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
cette petite leçon de skate devrait
peut-être permettre à Olivia d'acquérir
toute la technique nécessaire pour
surfer lors de sa dernière séance de
vagues qui aura lieu demain
[Musique]
au cœur de la vallée d'usage les
marcheurs arrivent au bout de leurs
efforts Lucienne et Robert qui ont tissé
des liens d'amitié commence à peine à
réaliser ce qu'ils ont vécu un moment
unique après les repas un petit repos
puis un dernier effort nous est demandé
pour arriver au col de Tizi d'outil
tu veux le lire pour moi s'il te plaît
2200 mètres d'altitude de quand même et
bien il a bien raison parce qu'en fait
ça remémore tous les petits détails
qu'on a oublié parce qu'en fait c'est un
peu tendance à se mélanger savant
capitaine il a pris vraiment c'est ça le
carnet de bord
donc vous allez plier à l'intérieur et
on rabat le dessus vous voyez ce que ça
fait
toujours pareil
retour à la civilisation c'est parti
Lucienne et ses amis marcheurs vont se
quitter le voyage prend fin riche de
futurs souvenirs je crois que que ce
soit un pays une vallée reculée ou même
une ville c'est à pied que tu le
découvres le mieux
il y a des gens pour qu'ils le voyage
c'est des paysans luxe moi le voyage
c'est aussi un petit peu pas trop
connaître à l'avance et c'est ce que je
fais
j'imagine absolument pas comment ça peut
être dans 50 ans que je sais pas si ça
va durer encore des générations
mais c'est bien que ça existe encore au
moins pour nous pour nous permettre de
le voir
et chez moi on dit que Dieu te bénisse
pour toi et tes enfants
et notre devoir c'est comme ça c'est
triste
un jour tu viendras nous voir inch'Allah
[Musique]
entre deux cours de taglac à Marrakech
Christian découvre le pays ce matin Saïd
lui organiser une sortie de pêche à
l'extérieur de la ville sur le barrage
almassira royaume d'un poisson qui ne
connaît pas le blackpass maintenant
la pêche
traditionnelle si c'est différent chez
nous les poissons
moi je suis venu à Marrakech pour
apprendre le Time lac j'aurais jamais
pensé de faire ça dans ma vie il a fallu
que je me déplace pour autonome
pour dire que
là faut que je change d'orientation de
métier ça ne travaille
Christian commence à y voir un peu plus
clair sur son avenir son désir de
reconversion prend forme même si le
stage de tadlak n'est pas encore
complètement terminé
Olivia elle est surfeurs sont à la
recherche d'un nouveau sport Tarek avait
juste aujourd'hui les conditions sont
excellentes pour s'amuser et pour
apprendre
ok alors amusez-vous bien
cette semaine j'ai gagné en confiance
déjà dans dans les conseils des
moniteurs parce qu'il y a derrière il y
a des encouragements donc ça ça fait du
bien et puis et puis moi je commence à
avoir un petit œil critique je vois ce
qui est ce qu'il faut faire ce qu'il
faut pas faire et je commence petit à
petit à me corriger
aujourd'hui on apprend énormément encore
quand tu le sais il y a le courant qui
tombe vers la gauche ok alors essaye de
ne pas te laisser trop emporter vers la
gauche parce qu'il y a trop de monde tu
vas surfer sur les 50 mètres la 70 m ici
tu te fais pas ennui avec les autres
[Musique]
Olivia n'est pas du genre à baisser les
bras elle veut à tout prix réussir à
surfer au moins une vague
ah ça va être dans la mousse et puis
travailler un petit peu ce que ma ce que
m'a donné Tarek comme information
surtout la position des jambes je suis
encore un peu en grenouille c'est pas
terrible il faut faire rentrer celui-là
comme ça faire sortir celui-là comme ça
et les genoux qui descendent
on est bien
la puissance vas-y comme ça
il a rectifié quelques quelques défauts
dans son cercle j'espère que elle va
capter ça bien comme il le faut quoi
[Musique]
j'ai réussi à redescendre une vague
pareil qui nous déçoit m'a dit que la
position des jambes c'était mieux donc
comme c'était mon objectif ce matin et
surtout pour le dernier jour je suis
contente je suis contente voilà tu as
bien avancé sur le séjour là ça a été
top top top merci pour tous les conseils
et un exemple aussi bien pour le surf
que pour la bonne humeur ici et c'est
vrai que le surf ça commence à apprendre
de la place
je pense que c'est quelque chose qui se
met en place dans ma vie et donc ce
voyage ça donne envie d'en faire un
autre et d'apprendre encore plus dans le
sport qui me qui me plaît
[Musique]
tout était très bien bon comme on dit
tant bon appétit maintenant ça a été
très très riche voilà
que mes enfants ils vont retrouver une
maman plus détendue aussi ça c'est sûr
que oui que je suis bourgeois du pas que
je suis bon mais là je vais rentrer chez
moi et puis je vais voir la vie
autrement en fait un voyage comme
celui-ci ça m'a rappelé des choses que
j'ai un petit peu connues dans mon
enfance
[Musique]
beaucoup d'images dans la tête
on reçoit beaucoup dans les sourires on
a ouvert une autre vision de la vie
travailler en faisant plaisir
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]